المواجهه بين واشنطن وبيكين لم تعد تقتصر
على السياسه والاقتصاد بل امتدت الى وسائل
التواصل الاجتماعي لا تيك توك بعد الان في
جميع الاجهزه الحكوميه الامريكيه البيت
الابيض يتخذ القرار بعد ان اخضع الموقع
الصيني للتدقيق في ظل وجود مخاوف امنيه 30
يوما حيز زمني امام الوكالات الفيدراليه
لحظر التطبيق على هواتفها واجهزتها بسبب
مخاطر على الامن القومي الامريكي مع منع
الاتصال عبر الانترنت بين هذه الاجهزه
والتطبيق قلق كبير يساور الولايات المتحده
من استغلال الصين للتطبيق للحصول على
بيانات المستخدمين الخاصه او لمحاوله نشر
معلومات مضلله او تقارير لصالح بيكين
الى جانب المخاوف الامنيه اتهامات متزايده
للمنصه تقول انها تستخدم خوارزميات تراقب
سلوكيات متصفحها ومن خلال ذلك تعتمد على
اسلوبين داخل الصين عبر التركيز على
المحتوى الجاد والثقافي وخارجها من خلال
تشجيع المحتوى الترفيهي القرار الامريكي
ياتي بوعيده قرار مماثل اصدرته الحكومه
الكنديه وحضرت وفقه تنزيل التطبيق على
الهواتف والاجهزه الالكترونيه التابعه لها
وكذلك فعلت المفوضيه الاوروبيه الاسبوع
الماضي الخارجيه الصينيه رفضت قرار البيت
الابيض قائله ان الولايات المتحده تقمع
الشركات الاجنبيه وتتجاوز مفهوم الامن
القومي
نعارض بشده للنهج الخاطئه للجانب الامريكي
والمتمثله في ارهاق مفهوم الامن القومي
واساءه استخدام القوه الوطنيه وقمع شركات
البلدان الاخرى بشكل غير منطقي تيك توك
يحظى بشعبيه كبيره ويستخدمه ثلثا
المراهقين في الولايات المتحده غير ان
المخاوف تتزايد من امكانيه استخدامه من
بيكن للتجسس على واشنطن بلال البجدين
العربيه